agents are hand-picked from various
aspects of society run through a
grueling vetting process and if
successful they are hard trained by
top-tier shd operatives this training
has then continued on for the remainder
of this service but this isn't all that
they're equipped with division agents
are armed with state-of-the-art weapons
and gear including shd technology in the
Isaac AI system in this video I'll be
covering the gear that all division
agents are issued after that become
full-fledged shd operatives starting
from the most basic equipment through to
the most advanced technology that the
strategic homeland division has at the
disposal
[Music]
[Music]
you
after activation all agents have 2 hours
to report to the designated rally point
as part of the training division agents
spend months preparing for this very
moment
critical emphasis is placed on being
ready both physically and
psychologically with only a short window
to react a large piece of the
preparation is the upkeep and
maintenance of the division issue go
back this arm aligned backpack should be
stocked with weapons and enough basic
supplies to last a minimum of 72 hours
in the field this includes water food
medical items ammunition protective
equipment tools gas masks emergency
blanket and any other basic mission
essential equipment depending on the
level of training and the time spent in
preparation agents will modify this kit
based on the individual needs and
expertise the Go Bag is a division
agents lifeline and has to be kept close
at all times with careful planning a lot
of the gear included has multi-use and
is equipped keeping in mind that the
agents still needs to be quick and agile
rather than being weighed down for
example instead of carrying water agents
will stock up on water purification
tablets or a purification bottle rather
than lugging around the extra weight of
bottled water as part of their training
agents in the field will keep an eye out
for any materials that could help them
for appear or upgrade of weapons and
equipment for example wire duct tape
electrical parts and fabric basically
anything that MacGyver would find useful
[Music]
one of the most important things to be
included in the Go Bag are the
medications and first-aid supplies once
agents successfully make it through the
vetting process they're immediately run
through a full series of vaccinations
there is referred to as the cocktail but
they're also given priority access to
all of the latest antiviral medications
available this is combined with the
cocktail makes agents out in the field
considerably more resistant to diseases
even ones that currently have no
functional vaccine or cure yet
discovered agents can often be deployed
with little information no backup and no
logistical support so it's up to them to
ensure the supplies last and are being
restocked when possible directive 51 s
continuity annex grants every division
agent the freedom to procure any item
for any location as long as the item is
not currently in direct physical
position of the civilian or friendly
unit this legal right of procurement
overrides all local anti looting laws
all division agents are trained to seek
recognize and procure valuable
operational items from the field
regardless of reason for activation
division agents must be equipped to be
able to not just deal damage but take it
there is the chance that no matter the
mission an agent will likely take a
bullet in one way or another for
survivability the strategic homeland
division is your basic set of protective
wearables but at the same time much like
the Go Bag agents are trained to search
the environment for items that could be
used to upgrade or replace their current
gear depending on each agents expertise
the type of gear that's chosen can vary
quite considerably all agents carry some
form of mask for protection against dust
and contaminants and most agents can be
seen wearing some sort of body armor
protective gloves and knee pads in order
to avoid trouble with other agencies and
departments division agents are also
equipped with amines to identify
themselves as government officials
[Music]
one of the strategic homeland division
x' greatest weapons is the
state-of-the-art technology developed by
the shd itself
shd tech or che tickers as other ways
not linked up to the shd global
satellite network shd tech provides
high-value real-time intelligence for
division agents engaged in field
operations produced by the strategic
homeland division three search &
Development Department s HD tech is
usually a term used for all proprietary
assets and systems that are created and
deployed by the division this includes
turrets drones seeker mines and some of
the most impressive augmented reality
systems ever created the division
network links all dedicated assets
controlled by the division like drones
and telecom satellites a piggy backs
onto existing civil commercial and
military network structures like cell
phone towers Wi-Fi hotspots and radio
navigation satellites this all creates a
seamless global web of connectivity in
the case of catastrophic emergency this
allows the reliability of the s HD
network this is crucial the s HD network
connects all field agents to the
Division HQ and the strategic government
decision-makers
Isaak is a highly advanced artificial
intelligence that is available to all
division agents Isaac's intelligence
provides key field operational services
to every agent including communications
analytics remote data collection and
retrieval weather information and
interaction with other technologies
Isaac can sort and analyze field sensor
information to provide technical support
relay alerts and updates identify human
targets or contacts via biometric
markers and set waypoints to objectives
Issac is basically an advanced version
of kalo that was developed by the
Pentagon's Defense Advanced Research
Projects Agency every division agent is
linked to the shd network via their
personal Isaak assistant the agency's
powerful computer network is routed
globally through an array of dedicated
Intel satellites in orbit the
sophisticated network systems track and
record every division agent recording
every encounter and generating field
data to create a shared picture for
informed analysis at all levels for an
agent in the field one of the most
important function that the network can
provide is the timely identification of
units during field encounters Isaac
draws from network databases to generate
a nearly flawless color-coded Friend or
Foe recognition system the affiliation
and Status of the unit is then displayed
directly on to the agents HUD in the
rear instance where the network goes
dark and the Friend or Foe system does
not work the agents are reminded to
proceed with extreme caution probably
the most iconic piece of division gear
is also one of the most important linked
up to the transceiver worn on the
agent's backpack the SmartWatch is the
direct line to Isaac and the shd network
the SmartWatch is the basic
functionality of the military-grade PDA
but it also includes communication both
peer-to-peer and white bent data
collection analysis enhanced situational
awareness electronic aggregation pulse
augmented reality enhancement scan tech
contact lenses and drone controller
interfaces this device gives the
division agents the ability to
communicate with fellow field agents in
HQ scan objects and identify field
targets hacked communication systems
electric locks and computers and scan
themselves for injury with the watch's
built-in
medical evaluation app the SmartWatch
also contains a special sensor that is
constantly scanning the environment for
physical chemical and biological
elements scan tech contact lenses
connected through the SmartWatch allows
Isaac to project an augmented reality
heads-up display directly over the
agents field of vision the AR HUD is
sent to the environment using Isaac's
senses these sensors help recognize and
display indicators and readouts like
threats and the tasks at hand hostile
forces globe red allies are marked by a
green health scan bar and a our
directional markers can be seen hovering
in the air leading to the next objective
scan tech lenses includes sensors that
generate power from eye movements this
allows the lenses to charge and store
energy as needed every division agent is
custom fitted with a set of silicon tip
2 earpieces to retrieve audio
communication as well as Isaac's
situational feedback for auto charging
buds feature rubber guards to protect
ears from flashbang damage or from other
loud noises all earpieces are connected
wirelessly to the SmartWatch Isaac
collects data from local devices and
sources such as smart phones
surveillance cameras satellites drones
and computers once it's sampled and
rendered 3d holographic images are
projected onto the agent's AR HUD lens
the images include audio of certain
events and sometimes identifying
information about the individuals
included this technique is called echo
and it serves as a useful source and
mapping out environments as well as
tracing hostile movements missing
persons or hidden caches of supplies and
equipment
division agents are equipped with
state-of-the-art gear the latest of
medical vaccinations and antivirals the
most advanced artificial intelligence
systems that the United States have to
offer and survival training that allows
them to cope in even the harshest of
conditions but even with all of this
given that agents are often isolated and
outnumbered there just isn't enough
training and preparation in the world to
truly know how a person would react if
they were fully backed into a corner
sure they have psychiatric assessments
that will filter out some of the crazies
like sociopaths and people who wear
socks to bed but there is nothing they
can truly do to test how some would
perform when it seems all hope is lost
thank you very much for watching I hope
this has answered a few questions as it
certainly did for myself like how the
division agents immune seemed so much
stronger than the average person anyway
that's it for this video I'll catch you
in the next one
Cheers
[Music]